all right uh so inspired by the fact
that we asked and points bet delivered
a prop bet that otherwise would not
exist today's draft
bets that we would love to be able to
make relating to things that we think
will happen in super bowl 55 to
determine the first pick is always a
trivial question chris which quarterback
won
a super bowl mvp award despite throwing
three interceptions wow they won a
super bowl mvp award
and they threw the three interceptions
i'm i'm that's what i'm not lying i'm
sweating this one out a little bit i
don't know
i feel like it's one from the early 70s
i'm just flushing this out a little bit
oh man i i i'm getting warm
getting warm you're getting warm you're
getting warm
it's early 70s right it is isn't that ah
it's
no not early but you're getting warm
you're get i didn't say you're hot
i said you're getting warm and he was
the mvp of the super bowl
with three interceptions football
historian
we gotta we got a lot of we got a lot of
those we're giving you extra time i'm
gonna go
terry bradshaw i'll go terry bradshaw
yes
he did in that dallas game that they won
35 31
right that one yeah super bowl 14
against the rams that they won 31 to 19.
he woke it up with that long throw to
john stalworth it's on the cover of
sports illustrated that i've got down in
my office where the ball's just going
over the hand
of the rams defensive back into john
stalwart's arms that was that was an
exciting super bowl between
13 and 14 that's when we got a glimpse
of what the super bowl could really be
because for the most part
the first the first dozen kind of boring
13 and 14 steelers wins both awesome all
right
uh i guess oh you get the first pick
then even though yeah
right right um what do you got historian
over here okay all right um i think the
first one
just like with this game okay this might
not be like the coolest sexiest one in
the world but i think it's still cool
statistically
like you're one of these guys is gonna
throw a 50-plus yard touchdown pass
that that is something that i feel like
kind of unique that i would bet on but
these two offenses
and as aggressive as these defenses can
be like
50 yard touchdown passes are rare but i
think you got the two offenses in
football
who throw the ball deep down the field
better than anybody
and two defenses that are willing to
take chances and put some guys on the
island so i'm gonna throw that one out
there first
all right i see i i i tried to get have
a little more fun with it than to
actually do
i will have more fun too i will don't
worry my my first one is the tom brady
primal scream that he still does
i would put the over under at two and a
half of those and take the over
you know where he does just does that
that that he just does that yell
that let's go and he just it looks like
he's doing the old
school primal scream he's been doing
that for years now and i've seen photos
of them doing it this year with the
buccaneers over under two and a half and
i would take the over
on seeing that tom brady primal scream
more than two and a half times on sunday
we i i know my next one was gonna be
something similar along
along the lines is that and i'm gonna go
with it you know not the primal scream
but
we're gonna see i think at least two
instance
incidents of frank clark and chris jones
talking crap to tom brady and them
getting into it behind the line of
scrimmage i
frank clark chris jones is the greatest
crap talker in football right now
anybody you talk to they always talk
about when you play the chiefs you got
to be ready for him
he doesn't back down from anybody i've
seen him do it to brady before and flank
frank clark's a similar similar mold so
that's one
i'm i'm interested to watch most teams
and this always bothers me bow down to
brady
and like you know they hit him and they
want to pick him up and dust them off
and like oh are you okay mr brady
kansas city has not done that and i
appreciate that about them and i think
they'll use that attitude to try to
semi you know intimidate a guy like
brady and i think defensive coordinator
steve spagnol is going to roll the tape
from super bowl 42
when it was justin tuck and michael
strahan and ocu manure all over tom
brady to get those guys even more
lathered up for the game next one for me
um
and you can bet on the color of the
gatorade that will be
dumped on the winning coach so in that
vein
i would like to bet and i would bet that
the color of bruce aryan's face
will indeed match the color of his shirt
and the odds for that are like minus 250
based upon what we've seen from bruce
arians
i don't know whether his face takes on
the color of what he's wearing
or he picks things out of his closet
based upon the color of his face that
day
we've seen shades of red we've seen
purple
so it will be some shade of red and i
would like to bet that the color of his
face
will match it yes i i well i
i would think red gatorade is gonna be a
popular bet for this one between these
two coaches
red on their you know red red jerseys
and everything like that
uh and and both have red faces to match
the gatorade that would be the one i'd
bet on for sure
um so that'll be interesting what was it
do you remember what kind of gatorade
andy reid got on him last year
i feel like it was purple i want to say
for some reason which i just i'm not a
fan of purple
oh i thought it was orange i can't
remember that was was it an orange one
i can't remember either all right my
neck my next one and matt casey is
saying it is orange so you are correct
um how about mahomes throwing an
underhand touchdown pass in the football
game
like do we see one of those that's
something that you know
andy reid two weeks off we've seen it
in a number of big games somehow
somewhere in the last game shovel pass
or something
last game right so you know whether we
see that again that'd be something i'd
like to throw some action on
see i think we take it next level we
want to see the behind the back pass
that came up last year as we got close
to the super bowl and he told me earlier
this year it's still in the arsenal
i may have to dust that off and write
about it at pft he said it's still there
he's got to do in the right time they
have to have a comfortable lead doesn't
want to do it at a time when
they may be super bowl is not the right
time let's still just wait
what if they're not what if they're up
what if they're up 21 okay
fine no i don't think that's safe nope i
wouldn't do 21.3 that's not enough this
year
not enough i i would not let's just wait
till next year and week two
against in some meaningless game all
right the next one for me is broadcast
related the number of times tony romo
will do that
[Music]
i
[Laughter]
uh i know i love that aspect of romo
broadcast and doing that
oh i don't know we'll be right back
after this i'm not sure if he was in or
out
um but i will just say i will say this
he he has morphed into more of a guy who
it's kind of like
watching the game with a friend like you
know agreed
the kind of stuff that you hear from the
people that you're sitting in the living
room with anyway
one more round you're right it's like
talking to a knowledgeable friend you're
exactly right
and you know with games like this we've
seen
you know he has the ability to because
he's got more time to study and
everything this is where he can be kind
of cool to go
he starts calling out plays and doing
things like that so that'll be fun to
watch to see if he's got a feel for
either one of these offenses
um all right like here's the last one
like legit question
like if you want to put over under on
how many snaps
tyree kill gets double teamed in this
one right i mean he went for 200 yards
in the first quarter in the first one
i got to think there's a different
approach with the buccaneers than tyree
kill
like what would you put it at over under
10
like 10 times i guess i'd say like
something like that i don't know that
that that to me would be a good bet
because i don't think that's totally in
todd
bowles wheelhouse to double all the time
one of the things in peter king's
football morning in america column the
dynamic of the buccaneers
secondary improving as much as it has
over the last seven games so
maybe they'll feel like they can they
can live dangerously and not double him
constantly and the problem is you double
him you got to deal with travis kelsey
so
uh it's i i would suspect they're going
to try to do what they did last time
remember last time they still almost won
the game even though the chiefs got out
to a 17 nothing lead all right last one
for me inspired by our interview last
week with robert sala
the number of times we see the little
old man jog from patrick mahomes
that's got to be a high number because
we do see it a lot now that
it's been flagged i think back and you
just see that kind of shuffling back to
the huddle
i'd say over under of 17 and a half
for the little old man jog yeah that's
it
yep
all right i i okay it's hilarious
i thought your microphone was dead there
for a second but yes we got the visual
well done
thank you very much yep i'm doing my
impersonations of my quarterbacks i get
to watch my little boy do it all day
long so i've got a good feel for it now
will he will he go uh all in on mahomes
full game long he's not gonna change his
mind this time is he right all game
and emotional it's like he'll be a
family member playing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the
latest news and